oui j'ai souhaité prendre la parole en
amont de de cet article qui va voir le
la présentation d'amendement créant la
fameuse taxe
streaming destiné à financer le Centre
national de la musique ayant été en 2019
rapporteur de ce projet de loi sur de
cette proposition proposition de loi
pardon sur le la création du Centre
national de la musique j'avais dans mon
propos introductif dit à l'époque et
noté la
tar princip de cette juste création qui
était son non financement et nous voilà
aujourd'hui plongé dans une situation
cfcenne si je devais paraphraser Bernard
Blier je dirais qu'on navigue dans le
sublime voilà nous avons donc le monde
de la musique plongé dans une Guéra
intense incapable de trouver l'harmonie
le 21 juin dernier jour de la Fête de la
Musique le président de la République ne
trouve pas mieux que de faire comme
d'habitude son solo et un solo qui dit
en deux mots si vous ne vous mettez pas
d'accord ça sera la taxe streaming telle
que préconisé par notre malheureux
collègue Julien Bargeton qui avait fait
ce rapport voilà et donc arrive le texte
le projet de loi de finance à
l'Assemblée et on pense à ce moment-là
puisque le groupe Renaissance porte
cette tax streaming également on pense
qu'il va faire partie du texte proposé
au 493
queeneni voilà le Sénat plongé
maintenant devant ses responsabilités
faut-il une taxe ne faut-il pas une taxe
si j'en juge par le nombre
d'amendements beaucoup souhaitent la
taxe et cette taxe va servir à financer
pensons-le le Centre national de la
musique ce que je voulais juste dire
sachant que le MIN monsieur le ministre
n'est certainement pas adepte des taxes
à bas rendement ni même Bercy que à
l'heure où l'argent coule à flot sur le
passe culture nous ne sommes même pas
capables de mettre entre 10 et 20
millions d'euros selon celui qui qui
tient la calculette pour financer le CNM
c'est une honte totale merci et avec
cette prise de parole je mets au voix
l'article 5 novau siè qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté article additionnel après
l'article 5 novciè C amendement
discussion commune et tout d'abord le
186 pour la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général
oui qui est donc
comment dirais-je parfaitement en phase
avec les la prise de parole de notre
collègue jean-rimmont Hugonet
effectivement on se propose alors moi je
je le dis aussi je ne suis pas par
nature un adepte des
taxes mais mais oui mais Monsieur le
Ministre ça ça me à la fois ça m'embête
de tenir une promesse faite par un
candidat devenu président la République
réélu et
par son
gouvernement qui est aux abonnés absents
qui ne tient pas parole et qui n'apporte
pas de solution donc vous le voyez au
regard
des comment dirais-je de la convergence
des amendements voilà nous mettons en
place un dispositif qui permet de
sécuriser le financement
euh puisque la la taxation de la mesure
de la musique enregistrée hein à
laquelle nous procédons va permettre
d'ailleurs de corriger un déséquilibre
entre les acteurs du spectacle vivant
qui contribue directement au financement
du CNM le Centre national de la musique
grâce aux recettes de billetterie et
ceux de la musique enregistré qui se
développe et qui n contribue aujourd'hui
qu'indirectement faiblement le
dispositif tel qu'il est imaginé permet
à la fois de préserver les petite
structure par une
tarification minorée et de construire un
dispositif beaucoup plus équilibré entre
les les major je dirais et puis les les
les les structures beaucoup plus petite
je veux également souligner que pour
avoir organisé la table ronde une table
ronde avec un certain nombre d'acteurs
alors on sent qu'il y a de
l'ambiance mais il y a manifestement une
majorité nette en faveur des dans les
participants en faveur de ce dispositif
voilà Monsieur le Ministre on vous remet
une copie ce que je souhaiterais en tous
les cas pour l'ensemble de ces acteurs
c'est que la volonté et le travail qui
est fait ici il soit également suivi des
faits parce que on n'a pas l'habitude de
faire des promesses pour le plaisir et
je le dis bien y compris en CR une taxe
puis après on regardera comment le
dispositif va
vivre merci amendement
[Musique]